[Musik]
ich bin dieses jahr wirklich zum
vollzeit youtuber gewonnen der traum dem
ich seit zehn jahren verfolge ist dieses
jahr realität geworden
bevor wir jetzt damit anfangen über das
letzte jahr zu sprechen erst mal zurück
zu meinem anfang damit ihr versteht
warum dieses jahr so krass für mich war
2011 habe ich damit angefangen meine
ersten youtube videos hochzuladen damals
mit kumpels vom schulhof dann über
jailbreak tutorials hin zu minecraft
let's play hin zur live videos die ich
quasi drei jahre gemacht hat ohne dass
sie irgend jemand interessiert haben sie
waren auch nicht besonders unterhaltsam
aber ich war unheimlich begeistert von
youtube über waiting pompei crime hin zu
einem monte marcel scorpion apa/red
immer so weiter das entwickelt sich
natürlich und ich war einfach riesiger
youtube film wirklich riesiger youtube
fan 2013 14 15 bin ich auf jedes youtube
treffen gefahren auf jedem video days
kein web video preis kein xxl tube a day
wurde ausgelassen und ich war umgeben
von 15 20 anderen leuten die alle
denselben traum hatten das ganze hat
mich meine komplette jugend begleitet
bis ich dann in meine armeezeit eine
bewerbung als cutter bei felix von der
laden eingereicht ich bin da wird ich
bin 18 jahre alt dieses video war mein
erstes video mit über 100000 aufrufen
das ist auch immer noch online und das
hat mich da noch mal richtig gepackt ein
video mit 100000 aufrufen weil das waren
nicht greifbaren nicht und ich wusste
ich werde alles dafür tun dass es klappt
max hat mich dann an youtube noch mal
neu herangeführt und habe gesagt hey ich
merke dass du eigentlich das selber
machen willst also habe ich mein studium
angefangen und parallel ein paar youtube
videos gemacht die zu dem zeitpunkt auch
noch ein bisschen konzeptlos waren und
so weiter und plötzlich habe ich gemerkt
wofür ich eigentlich wirklich brennt
youtube videos machen den hohen
qualitätsstandard erfüllen nicht
erfüllen und bei denen ich selber noch
was mitnehmen kann wo ich selber neue
erfahrungen machen dabei habe ich aber
gemerkt youtube wirklich machen zu
wollen ist kein 40 stunden job sondern
so wie ich das gerne machen möchte
eigentlich ein job bei dem man quasi
anderthalb stellen belegt also von
morgens bis abends kopf lässt sich da zu
sein und wirklich auch einfach aktiv
daran zu arbeiten deswegen habe ich mein
studium pausiert das erst mal hinten
angeschoben und mich dafür entschieden
komplett beenden zu wollen und es stand
aber alles noch so auf der kippe ist war
nicht so dass ich mehr ist hätte leisten
können büro zu nehmen das war nicht so
dass wir einfach eine neue kamera hätte
kaufen können oder videos umzusetzen
ohne dabei aufs geld zu achten ich habe
aber weiter gemacht und irgendwann ist
dieser punkt gekommen und zwar anfang 20
21 und deswegen ist dieses jahr so
unglaublich besonders für mich ich bin
dieses jahr vollzeit youtuber geworden
was denkt mein größter traum jemals war
ich kann von youtube leben und ich lebe
für youtube das ist kein witz und ich
werde da wirklich ein bisschen emotional
weil
youtube mein leben ist so dumm sich das
anhört und genau dieses jahr möchte ich
jetzt mit euch ein bisschen
rekapituliert weil es ist definitiv das
krasseste jahr das ich jemals erleben
durfte das erste video in 20 21 wie
sollte es anders sein war eine folge
rolex trader rolex trade up das projekt
über dass mich die meisten von euch
gefunden haben dass dave projekt und
mein absolutes traumprojekt ein projekt
in dem ich super viele verschiedene
sachen machen kann aber es trotzdem
irgendwie in einem format gebündelt und
angefangen bei sportwetten zu rolex über
poker zu rolex durch integration zu
rolex und so weiter wir haben wirklich
eine menge erlebt und ich habe da
wirklich arbeit reingesteckt klar es hat
immer mal wieder pausen gegeben und ich
wusste nicht so recht hey wie kann ich
überhaupt noch geld verdienen wie wie
soll ich das machen was lohnt sich was
wollen die leute sehen aber es war
wegweisend für mich weil ich
herausgefunden habe welcher stil von
videos und welche themen mich wirklich
interessieren oder auch überhaupt nicht
interessieren und alles was ihr jetzt
haben wir 20 21 in rolex trainer erlebt
eine fährte
90 euro gewinn gemacht ist schon traurig
die folge nicht mit plus beendet zu
haben
[Musik]
2000 euro verdiente
425 euro
30 und 50 kilo säcke sind das
insgesamt ist das projekt
wir konnten profit machen das war die
einfachste und 20 euro die ich jemals
wollte den kauf von wohnungen oder 2001
75 programm mich ausgeschieden
das geht so schnell auf youtube weil man
nicht aufhört zu arbeiten dass man das
gar nicht alles realisiert außer man
setzt sich jetzt mal hin und plant für
ein video was jetzt gerade mache während
ich zu euch spreche und dann erst mal
merkt was dieses jahr alles passiert ist
was man alles gemacht hat und so geht es
dann auch weiter mit der gamestop
geschichte ich habe 16.000 euro im
gamestop investiert und das ist passiert
[Musik]
die gemeinden
plötzlich hatte ich einen tesla völlig
verrückt der youtube traum und
gleichzeitig auch die youtube du lys die
mit dem ersten verdienten geld sich ein
teures auto kaufen und ja so war es aber
tatsächlich bin ich nach wie vor super
happy damit und es hat alles
funktioniert würde ich euch das auch
raten nein aber ich habe es gemacht es
hat funktioniert und es ist unglaublich
darauf zurück zu schauen und zu merken
dass man das wirklich erlebt hat und
dass das funktioniert hat und dass man
dumm genug war so eine aktion so ein
risiko einzugehen es ist dieses jahr
passiert die ich mit diesem video kam
aber auch die ersten größeren
kooperation dieses video folgende videos
eigentlich fast alle leuchtturm videos
auf einem kanal dieses jahr wurden von
einer firma unterstützt sie sich clark
nennen und die unterstützen auch dieses
video niederschlag ist ein
versicherungsmakler der auf youtube
dieses jahr unheimlich viel beworben
wurde viele leute haben dafür geworben
viele leute hat es gemerkt dass es so
viel beworben wurde und ich war einer
derjenigen die es beworben hat und nach
wie vor guten gewissens lag ist ein
online versicherungsmanager bei dem ihr
versicherungen vergleichen könnt und in
der werbung wurde es einfach immer so
gesagt ihr die beste versicherung für
euch findet ich habe klagt getestet
benutze ist selber und ich bin auch der
meinung das ist das beste
versicherungsvergleichs portal ist das
ist momentan gibt bei aber du hast doch
bestimmt davon gehört dass klagt das
versicherungs mandat hat und im prinzip
komplett für dich entscheiden könnte ja
aber ich habe mich damit auseinander
gesetzt und habe herausgefunden dass sie
natürlich keine verträge in eurem namen
abschließen in eurem namen kündigen dies
versicherungs mandat ist wichtig damit
zugriff auf die versicherung gewährt
wird und ihr quasi über die app die
sachen buchen könnt damit klagt das für
euch wenn ihr das wollt ich liebe
digitalität und ich liebe es sachen
schwarz auf weiß zu haben und das gefühl
habe ich bei klagt dass sie
sicherung anhand objektivität
beschreiben weil eben alles aufgelistet
ist was an dieser versicherung gut oder
schlecht oder teurer oder günstiger ist
weswegen ich das selber persönlich auch
eine versicherungsmakler bevorzuge ich
bewerbe das weil ich selber benutze für
den reibungslosen und einfachsten
versicherungsabschluss ist es für mich
der moz kombinieren dass makler man dazu
geben ihnen die arbeit zu überlassen
nicht nicht durch bergeweise an
verträgen kämpfen zu müssen und quasi
schwarz auf weiß versicherungen
vergleichen zu können ob das ist der
richtige anbieter für euch ist ob das
der richtige weg für euch ist müsst ihr
im endeffekt selber entscheiden und wenn
es für euch der richtige weg sein sollte
dann klickt auf den ersten blick in der
video beschreibung ladet euch klar unter
unvergleichbar versicherung dass mit den
experten das wird immer in den playoffs
gesagt aber das ist kein witz da sitzen
wirklich experten und ihr könnt one on
one beratung bekommen bei bestimmten
themen wenn ihre spezielle versicherung
braucht oder sonstwas es funktioniert
außerdem war clark auch in einem meiner
favorite videos dieses jahr partner und
hat möglich gemacht dass ich mit der
community 500 kilometer mit dem fahrrad
ohne training nach paris gefahren bin
die unglaubliche heldenreise von ansgar
der mit einem gang ohne helm mit
wirklich schlechtestem equipment und
plakette die halbe auseinanderfallen war
von köln bis nach paris gefahren ist und
das ganze quasi ohne uns im alleingang
weil endlich hinterher gekommen ist es
war wirklich unglaublich und hat sich
fast angehört wie eine fake story weil
es so verrückt aus diesem video ist dann
eine idee entstanden wo wir mit ansgar
für ein paar tage nach mallorca geflogen
sind das erste mal außerhalb der paris
reise mit ihm außerhalb von deutschland
waren das waren unglaubliche videos und
genau das ist das was ich gerne erzeugen
möchte was sich aber nicht künstlich
erzeugen lässt das sind verrückte
stories das sind krasse sachen die
passieren wenn man einfach videos filmt
das lässt sich nicht planen und das ist
das was im endeffekt meinen kanal
ausmacht direkt nach diesem video ging
es weiter mit studio
ein zweiter kanal den ich dieses jahr
parallel zu meinem hauptkanal gelaunched
habe den ich nur produzieren wo ich
selten vor der kamera vorkomme und den
vermutlich die meisten von euch kennen
insgesamt sind dort dieses jahr 34
videos gekommen was unglaublich
aufwendig aber eine mega gute erfahrung
war für diesen kanal gibt es für 2022
riesige pläne dazu können wir noch nicht
besonders viel sagen aber nur dass ihr
wisst wir arbeiten weiter daran und es
kommt wieder raus nur ganz kurz der
kanal ist mit drei leuten im endeffekt
entstandenes kortmann waren drei leute
von denen zwei parallel den den
hauptkanal geschmissen haben also wir
haben dieses jahr so viel gearbeitet das
quasi keine zeit für andere sachen übrig
ist das muss ich auch nochmal kurz sagen
einfach damit man das wirklich versteht
ich habe so mäßig meine beziehung 2020
aufgegeben um mehr zeit für youtube
videos zu haben ich treffe außer den
engsten kreis der auch youtube videos
macht wenige meiner freunde aus der
heimat und so weil keine zeit bleibt
meine eltern machen sich sorgen um mich
weil ich den ganzen tag nur vom
bildschirm hänge am planen bin schnell
reise und so weiter also so cool und so
beneidenswert dieser dieses youtube
leben manchmal aussieht so so hart und
aufwendig ist es dann im endeffekt doch
wirklich also man ist von einem naja
halbzeit job in der uni zu einem
anderthalb zeit job in der
selbstständigkeit bei dem man kein
festes gehalt bekommt bei dem man sachen
planen muss bei dem man sich mit
rechtsstreits auseinandersetzt muss ganz
viel kram den man gar nicht so sieht die
leute bei denen ihr merkt hey die die
stecken wirklich herzblut in ihren
content und bei leuten die jeden tag
auftritt live gehen und bei leuten die
instagram sogar dass hier immer gut
auszusehen hat da ist das unheimlich
viel arbeit unheimlich viel arbeit ich
sage das nicht um mitleid zu bekommen
sondern einfach nur um euch zu zeigen
wie wichtig dass den meisten leuten ist
euch bestmöglichen content zu liefern
und viel für euch da zu sein vielleicht
zu sein und so weiter es ist trotz
alledem natürlich der cluster traumjob
denn er ermöglicht auch dass man ein
video reihe macht in der man einfach
luxuriöse hotels oder businessklasse
testet was ich dieses jahr natürlich
auch zuhauf getan
[Musik]
und auch wir nicht vergessen dass dieses
jahr sachen kam die fake wahlplakate
aufhängen bei dem wir hoffen sich einige
von euch dazu animieren konnten wirklich
wählen zu gehen ihr züge getestet haben
ich in amerika war parallel probiert
habe nun brennt aufzubauen auch wenn es
deutlich schwieriger ist als es von
außen aussieht und ich dreimal nach
istanbul fliegen musste und es im
endeffekt doch nicht so richtig
funktioniert hat es passiert super viel
und ich bin unheimlich dankbar dass
machen zu können für 20 22 steht uns
riesiges bevor ich habe super coole
pläne folgeprojekte für rolex trade up
denn scheinbar geht rolex trader gerade
zu ende im januar kommt das große finale
und dann muss ich mich erst mal wieder
ein bisschen neu orientieren aber ich
habe da schon einige sachen in planung
also 20 22 wird ein absoluter traum und
deswegen hier nochmal ein riesiges
ehrliches dankeschön für 20 21 danke für
euren anhaltenden support danke für
euren wachsenden support wir sind auf
dem hauptkanal fast 400.000 abonnenten
wenn ich das meinem 13 jährigen ich
erzählen würde dann würde aus allen
wolken fallen wir haben 130 videos
dieses jahr gemacht bist du dir 2022
noch mal krasser ich hoffe dass es mit
der brand alles läuft und wir arbeiten
weiter daran euch den content zu liefern
den wir uns selber anschauen würden und
ich glaube das steht an allererster
stelle für uns für 2022 wir wollen nicht
runter fahren sollen nicht weniger
machen es wird alles nur besser voller
schöner hoffentlich
ohne dass die darunter zusammenklappen
und ich hoffe dass ihr ein schönes
weihnachtsfest hatte gut ins neue jahr
rutscht und ich danke vielmals für euren
support das ist wirklich krass danke